[Music]
ruth bader ginsburg said
fight for the things that you care about
but do it in a way
that will lead others to join you
oh in these divisive times that was a
good word rest in peace miss ruth
wow wow
fight for the things you care about but
do it in a way that will lead
others to join you that is a
lost art nowadays
people feel like if someone doesn't
agree with them someone doesn't agree
with you they must be destroyed
you can't merely disagree with someone's
ideas you have to destroy them
we have to cancel them the cancel
culture is out there
i don't like the way you phrased that
tweet you crazy boomer
so i'm not going to listen to you
anymore
your loss because i'm not going to shut
up
i'm still gonna keep doing exactly what
i was doing you can cancel me
but you only canceled me from your life
because see
i own this and i don't get canceled
unless
i cancel me isn't that neat
i can't get fired unless you fire me
from your life but that's just your loss
then
because you're narrow-minded and stupid
so i got lots of people that i don't
agree with things with them on things
that i can learn from
but i have what's known as the ability
to think
instead of single bipolar thinking where
you know or i just have to be either i
have to be orange man bad
orange man bad you know i mean you
people lose your minds out there
and you know one little thing and you're
just like looking for a reason to be
pissed off about everything
my gosh ruth bader was onto something
here fight for all the things you care
about
but do it in a way that will lead others
to join you
this is so this is the most polarized
time
and i don't know exactly what's caused
it but it is really polarizing
and you would think something like covid
could get people to work together and
care about each other
and in pockets we have we've done a good
job with that
but man i've just had to turn off the
television it's just
dumb it's just dumb
so fight fight
for the things you care about but do it
in a way that will lead others to join
you
so if i can get you to join me i want
you to join me
if you don't if you're mad at me you'll
just have to go away but we're going to
do what we're going to do
because the stuff we teach works it's
right
and if you don't like something about it
that's just your fault and we'll deal
with that